a few years ago Teen Vogue celebrated
the day by gathering around a group of
sullen Surly Native American girls to
scowl at us and tell us quote the real
history behind Thanksgiving watch Happy
Thanksgiving America I'm Donna and I'm
here with my friends to tell you the
real history behind this
holiday growing up I knew that what they
told you in school about Thanksgiving
wasn't true that's not the true story
the true story behind Thanksgiving was
after every killing of a whole village
these European settlers celebrated it
and they called it Thanksgiving but it
wasn't until Abraham Lincoln became
president that it became an official
holiday you think you're celebrating
family togetherness and all that happy
stuff but that's not what you're
celebrating these unhappy Native
American girls they will tell you what
you're celebrating and they say that you
are celebrating murder and death